welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston with Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 mere days away we are facing the
culmination of story lines nine years in
the making across seven MCU titles
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 Guardians
Volume 2 Avengers Infinity War Avengers
end game Thor 11 Thunder I am Groot and
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special so yeah there's a lot to catch
up on for all of these characters and
while this may be sacred Creed living in
the minds of many of us for many others
of us there's a lot of oh yeah that yeah
him so I'm gonna break down the full MCU
history of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and really everything you need to know
going into volume three let's start with
guardians volume 1 1988 Peter Quill's
mother Meredith dies of brain cancer and
young Peter gets abducted by yondu
leader of a group of space pirates
called the ravagers yondu and his crew
mistreat Peter but essentially raise him
as one of their own kid Moran because
he's small and good for thieven Peter as
an adult acquires an orb on Morag on a
ravager assignment from Ronan the
Accuser he is a Cree militant who hates
hates xandar and really he needs to get
that orb
orb at Titan Thanos for the infinity
stone inside of it the purple Power
Stone Thanos has two adopted daughters
Gamora and nebula both of whom he
adopted from civilizations he killed 50
of in the past and he pits the two of
them against each other so they kind of
hate each other sothena sends Gamora
after the orb and Peter and Gamora fight
for the Orban xandar wild Rocket and
Groot a team of bounty hunters tried to
claim yondu's bounty on Peter for going
behind his back and all four of these
that end up getting arrested by
the Nova Corps that's the military
authority of the planet xandar the four
are detained and sent to the Kiln the
prison it is here where they meet Drax a
killer who hates Ronan ethanos and
everyone associated with them for
killing his wife and daughter and in
this case he blames Gamora for it the
five of these idiots end up escaping the
Kiln and they head to Nowhere a severed
head of a Celestial that has been mined
for brain tissue by The Collector
tanelier Tavon The Collector explains
the backstory of the Infinity Stones and
his assistant Karina tries to grab the
Power Stone and blows the place up at
this point the ravagers in ronin's
forces arrive there's a fight Ronan gets
away with the Power Stone turns on
Thanos and targets xandar the Guardians
end up teaming up with the ram Avengers
against Ronin nebula fights Gamora but
cuts off her arm to escape Groot ends up
sacrificing himself to save the others
Peter uses his mother's mixtape the
music is very important to these movies
to distract Ronan with the dance battle
while rocket and Drax bust his hammer to
free the Power Stone Peter is
interestingly able to hold the Power
Stone helped by the others and Ronan
dies they end up leaving the Power Stone
on xandar tricking yondu into thinking
he has it and we learn that yondu had
abducted Peter on orders by Peter's
father rocket replant screwed's
Twigs to form groot's progeny later
known as Baby Groot it was a really fun
movie however the duck shows up at one
point there's lots of Easter eggs and
then on to Guardians volume 2. this
movie Set mostly three months after the
first film but it has a prologue showing
Peter's father ego a Celestial who can
take a human form hooking up with
Meredith quill in 1980 and we later
learned that ego had mated with
countless beings seeking an offspring
who could carry his Celestial Gene in
order to help power his expansion Across
the Universe and we learned that he was
the one who gave Meredith quill that
brain tumor three months after the first
film The Guardians are helping the
genetically super interior Sovereign led
by Aisha fighting obelisks trying to
feed on the sovereign's precious anilax
batteries for payment they take the
captured nebula and Rockets steal some
of those batteries so The Sovereign
Fleet chases them but ego saves them
Peter Gamora and Drax go with ego and
his Aid the empath mantis to ego's
Planet Aisha sends yondu after the
Guardians and the ravagers find Rocket
Baby Groot and nebula but nebula
disables yondu to favor his mutineers
led by taserface but yondu's loyal
craglin helps them escape and they kill
off the other ravagers meanwhile on
ego's planet they realize ego had
actually killed off all of his other
Offspring and just wants to use Peter as
a battery to kill the rest of all life
in the universe in this expansion
everyone rejoins to fight ego and blow
up his brain in the planet's core with a
bomb made of those anilax batteries
yandu sacrifices himself to save Peter
and earns a ravager funeral and we
learned in a post-credit scene that
Aisha has bred a genetically perfect
being named Adam Warlock in a golden
cocoon now the next time we see the
Guardians is actually in Avengers
Infinity War the Guardians now bit older
come upon Thor in the massacred as
Guardians and we learned Thanos is on
the move to get Infinity Stones rocket
and teenage group joined Thord and knit
a belieer to craft a new god-killing
weapon Stormbreaker using groot's
severed arm as the handle the other
Guardians go to Nowhere to find Thanos
having already gotten the reality Stone
he leaves with Gamora and she discovers
that he has been torturing nebula Thanos
and Gamora godivormir for the Soul Stone
which requires Thanos to sacrifice
someone he loves and this is how Gamora
dies Peter Quill Drax semantis meet Tony
Stark doctor strange and Peter Parker on
Titan to fight Thanos nebula joins The
Fray and they nearly beat Thanos but
quill realizes Thanos killed Gamora and
loses his temper allowing Thanos to
regain the upper hand and complete his
Stone Quest taking him back to Earth
where he snaps and on Titan quill Drax
and mantis all dust along with Doctor
Strange meanwhile on Earth Groot dusks
nebula is Left Behind with Stark on
Titan and Rocket stays on Earth with the
Avengers now during all this in Captain
Marvel we learned that Ronan the Accuser
had a pass with Carol Danvers in the 90s
because Captain Marvel is set amidst all
the drama with decree in the Cosmic
Landscape in the MCU drama that will
continue to play out with ronan's
successor in the Marvels coming this
November but that's not really relevant
to the Guardians of the Galaxy
necessarily okay but on to Avengers end
game Rocket and nebula joined the
Avengers failed attempt to strike Thanos
back but we learned that Thanos had
destroyed the Infinity Stones and Thor
decapitates him five years past the
Avengers figure out time travel and
Rocket nebula join the time heists so
streaming services like Netflix hide
thousands of shows and movies from you
based on your location and while it'd be
great to you know just head on over to
the UK or to Japan to watch all this
stuff it's just easier to use expressvpn
we have been using expressvpn for years
at new rockstars and it's something that
we've just really rely on to create all
this stuff for you guys with expressvpn
I can control which country Netflix
thinks I'm in with just a single click
there are over 90 countries to choose
from so every time I run out of stuff to
watch I just switch to another country
and unlock new shows so for instance say
you want to watch Jurassic Park you
can't do that on the Netflix in the
United States but with just one tap of a
button expressvpn lets you change your
location to Germany which is apparently
where you need to go to find the
dinosaurs and it's not just for Netflix
you can use expressvpn to unlock shows
on other streaming services too like I
like to watch Graham Norton on BBC
iPlayer it's free and it's only
available in the UK expressvpn is also
super fast and it works on your phone
your laptop even your smart TVs so that
you can watch the shows from the comfort
of your couch or on the go with zero
buffering no wonder Express CPN has
already been called the best VPN of
2023. expressvpn is a must-have so make
sure you go to expressvpn.com new
rockstars you'll get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free nebula
gets swapped with the past era of nebula
who is still loyal to Thanos and she
sneaks in with the Avengers back to the
present and reopens the time portal so
past arithanos and his forces and past
era Gamora all arrive at the present
good nebula kills evil nebula and Gamora
turns against Thanos and since Hulk has
snapped everyone back a portal opens
from Titan and quill and tracks and
mantis all returned the ravagers join in
the Battle of Earth as well they end up
beating Thanos passed era Gamora goes
her own way and Thor joins the Guardians
of the Galaxy which now include Raglan
as they all head out to space now the
Guardians do show up briefly in Thor
love and thunder the movie opens with
Thor getting back in shape and the
Guardians on a series of interesting
looking missions we don't learn too much
about them the longest one we see is
this battle on the planet of indigar but
after the indigarians reward them with
these two screaming goats the Guardians
of the Galaxy go their separate way from
Thor and cord well also 2022 was
released I am Groot these shorts take
place between Guardians volume 1 and
Guardians Volume 2 and they show baby
groot's Evolution from a potted plant
into the adorable Scamp who dances with
amorphous beings and makes an art
project for rocket and the others
they're all very very sweet I highly
recommend checking them out but this
brings us to last year's Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special that
establishes the Guardians have settled
back on nowhere as their new home mantis
reveals to Peter that she was also a
child of ego making the two of them half
siblings nowhere security is overseen by
nebula and craglin and Cosmo the space
dog one of the collectors collections
from the first film a dog who is
telekinetic in the special track cement
is cheer up Peter by kidnapping Kevin
Bacon from Earth so going into Guardians
volume 3 here's where things stand Peter
Quill Remains the son of the celestial
ego and the human Meredith quill who for
whatever reason resulted in Peter being
the only one of ego's Offspring to carry
the celestial Gene you now captains the
guardian's third ship the Bowie Gamora
is the branch timeline variant stuck in
the present after Avengers endgame with
no memories of the Guardians from volume
1 or volume 2 or Infinity war and before
volume 3 she was not with the guardians
but it is suspected that she might have
joined up with the other ravager pirate
captains from Volume 2 including stakara
ogord Martin X Krueger and Mainframe
rocket whom director James Gunn has
called The Secret protagonist of this
entire Trilogy is reminder not a raccoon
he's really the creation of we learned
the high evolutionary Herbert Windham
the villain of volume 3 and we're going
to learn a lot of Rocket's backstory in
this film Groot is now a larger swole
group form amantis now feels more of a
kinship with the Guardians as Peter's
half-sister Drax is still a big
hilarious idiot nebula now oversees the
guardian's new home of nowhere she has a
new nanotech weave are built for her by
rocket after she gifted rocket Bucky's
vibranium arm fraglin also looks over
nowhere carrying yondu's gaka Arrow he's
joined by Cosmo the space dog who again
is telekinetic Aisha's creation of Adam
Warlock played by Will Poulter is now
hunting the Guardians down and it sounds
like he's gonna be a big dumb baby who
was literally born yesterday NOW Thor
and other major MC heroes are not
expected to show up in this movie but we
will likely learn more about celestials
and Cosmic genealogy in the MCU and
James Gunn's long-lost Easter egg from
the first two movies remains hidden but
will be decodable from location
coordinates in this movie so keep a
sharp eye out for those and this will be
Jane's gun's final Guardians movie for
the MCU as he now heads DC films for
Warner Brothers Zoe Saldana said that
she's done playing Gamora de Bautista
signal this is the end of Drax too so
much like Avengers end game we can
expect some rare finality from a Marvel
film and my live stream breakdown and Q
a of this movie will be Friday May 5th
at noon Eastern on the Deep dive channel
so be sure to subscribe to that and you
can support us by grabbing this rocket
science 89.3
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at EA boss follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]